the very beginning of the nun teaser
says make sure you watch to the end in
big bold caps no I don't know if that's
just for YouTube but there's nothing at
the end of this teaser it just shows the
release date and then it ends so I don't
know why it says that
but anyway make sure you watch this
thing's you miss the video all the way
to the end another year and other
installments in the conjuring franchise
this time it focuses on the nun demon
Ballack who's been teased at one point
or another in all four conjuring films
so far the opening shot of the teaser
shows this painting it looks a lot like
what West Dakota looks like when he
first wakes up in the morning but this
is actually the painting that Idi Warren
paints based off his dream in the
conjuring - that's the movie where the
Warrens have their big showdown with the
Baloch but the nun is a prequel so this
is gonna be taking place away before the
Boren's are even in the picture I'll get
back to the overall timeline of events
later in this video but the reason that
shows this painting relates to the
voice-over role it I had a series of
visions when I was younger and after
each one ended the same thought I'd be
stuck in my head let's posit there so
this girl has visions of the nun just as
Lorraine Warren did in the conjuring -
and Ed Warren did in his dream so right
away I would make the guess that she's a
medium then I saw who was speaking these
words it's an actress named taissa
farmiga the sister of Vera Farmiga who
plays Lorraine Warren in the conjuring
phones we may only be three shots into
the teaser but I think I already got a
theory I think this girl is somehow
related to Lorraine Warren the strobe
does look to be on the younger side and
with this being a prequel set in 1952
that would make this girl in Lorraine
right around the same age they probably
aren't sisters seeing as how the nun
takes place in Romania and Lorraine was
born in Connecticut but they probably
share some common ancestor who passed
down the media mobility to both of them
if you're wondering how I know what year
this takes place in I noticed that this
shot in the teaser is the same as this
location in the post-credits sequence
from Annabel creation where this happens
so as promised quick run down to the
timeline the earliest-known event is the
creation of the Annabelle doll in
Annabelle creation which I guess is why
it's called that then in 1943 the car
accident from Annabelle creation takes
place the nun takes place nine years
later in 1952 three years after that in
1955 is the rest of Annabelle creation
which leads right into Annabelle's
adoption 12 years later in 1967
Annabelle returns to kill her adoptive
parents beginning the events of
Annabelle 1971 is the conjuring in 1976
is the conjuring 2 I bring up the
timeline because the history of Alec is
unique in that it stretches at least 24
years across 3 different countries it
almost makes me wonder if there's
something that happens in the none that
puts a curse on the family and sends
VALIC to try to kill ed and Lorraine
Warren
so moving on with the teaser as this
creepy old voice is telling us about the
abbeys long history or shown this little
card if you mirror it it says the nun at
the bottom there and the eyes and mouth
are crossed out in ink the overall shape
of this image resembles the stained
glass window so it kind of makes me
think that the nun deity it was once an
agent of good before being possessed by
the evil demon Ballack and that idea
kind of fits in with this next shot
a door with the words Finney Tiki Deo
burned into it it's a Latin phrase
translating to this ends a god or as the
priest puts it and I had to use
subtitles to understand what he was
saying God ends here so whatever is
behind this door has got to be akin to
many of the other haunted locations in
the series I wonder if whoever designed
this logo was a 9 inch nails fan but
anyway that's it for this teaser I'll be
sure to come back with a more things you
missed when we get a full trailer and of
course when we get the full movie this
September if you're new here my name is
cz and I also ride and narrate my own
horror stories here on the channel check
out this one about the man who finds
some disturbing drawings in his
daughter's backpack and if you're a fan
of anything creepy you're definitely
gonna want to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week bring
that death Bell notifications see he's
got the right idea and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive
you
[Music]